Thank you.
My mirror-neuron subsystem suggests that this is going to replace phones
in not too long.
Ray, how's it going?
Ray: Great. We're live today.
(Applause)
MG: Ray, give the crowd a gift
of the holographic brain we saw from the video earlier.
Guys, this is not only going to change phones,
it's also going to change the way we collaborate.
Thank you so much.
Thanks, Ray.
Ray: You're welcome.
(Applause)
MG: So folks, this is the message that I discovered in that bar in 2011:
The future of computers is not locked inside one of these screens.
It's right here, inside of us.
(Applause)
So if there's one idea that I could leave you with here today,
it's that the natural machine is not some figment of the future,
it's right here in 2016.
Which is why all hundred of us at Meta,
including the administrative staff,
the executives,
the designers, the engineers --
before TED2017,
we're all going to be throwing away our external monitors
and replacing them with a truly and profoundly more natural machine.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)
Thank you, appreciate it.
Thanks, guys.
Chris Anderson: So help me out on one thing,
because there've been a few augmented reality demos
shown over the last year or so out there.
And there's sometimes a debate among technologists
about, are we really seeing the real thing on-screen?
There's this issue of field of view,
that somehow the technology is showing a broader view
than you would actually see wearing the glasses.
Were we seeing the real deal there?
MG: Absolutely the real deal.
Not only that,
we took extra measures to shoot it with a GoPro through the actual lens
in the various videos that you've seen here.
We want to try to simulate the experience for the world
that we're actually seeing through the glasses,
and not cut any corners.
CA: Thank you so much for showing us that.
MG: Thanks so much, I appreciate that.